بينما تتجه الانظار الى العاصمه الامريكيه
واشنطن حيث تعقد القمه الامريكيه
الافريقيه بحضور رؤساء وقاده 49 دوله على
مدى ثلاثه ايام
تستبقوا اداره الرئيس الامريكي الحدث
باعلان التزام الولايات المتحده بتقديم 55
مليار دولار لقاره سمراء على مدى السنوات
الثلاث المقبله
مستشار الامن القومي في البيت الابيض
على الطاوله مؤكدا ان بلاده ستعلن دعما
انضمام الاتحاد الافريقي الى مجموعه
العشرين خلالها
اشار ايضا الى ان ايضا سيعين ممثلا خاصه
لتنفيذ ما يخرج عن القمه هو ان بلاده لن
تفرض شروطا خلالها لدعم اوكرانيا
قمه تاتي بعد قرابه ثمان سنوات من انعقاد
القمه الامريكيه الافريقيه الاولى والتي
عقدت في العام 2014
وجرى خلالها مناقشه مبادرات في مجالات
الطاقه والخدمات الماليه وتغير المناخ
والامن الغذائي والرعايه الصحيه
لتثير تساؤلات حول ما اذا كانت امريكا
تسعد اتباع نهج جديد في القاره السمراء
والالتفات الى مصالحها هناك عبر اطلاق
تعاونات المشتركه ام ان هذا هو انضمام
متاخر الى مضمار سباق الجاري في افريقيا
ومنافسه كل من الصين وروسيا اللتين كانت
قد شقتها طريقهما فيها بالفعل